- It is both a great pleasure
and a great privilege to
introduce our guest speaker
today, Mr. Rizvi Hassan,
who reaches us from Dhaka, Bangladesh.
Rizvi Hassan has completed many projects
for the Bangladeshis and,
for the Rohingya refugees in the world's
largest refugee camp in Kutupalong.
Within five years of completing
his bachelor of architecture
at the Bangladesh University
of Engineering and Technology,
Rizvi Hassan received
numerous awards and accolades.
In 2020, his Beyond Survival safe space
in Teknaf refugee camp was
singled out by The Guardian as
one of the world's top 10 new
architectural projects.
Two years later in 2022,
he received the distinguished
and much coveted
Aga Khan Award for Architecture.
He has been named by the UN
a real life hero and acknowledged by OCHA,
the United Nations Office
for Humanitarian Affairs
for his work with the Rohingyas.
Rizvi Hassan has innovated
on so many different fronts,
broken so many stereotypes
and barriers that it is
impossible to do justice to his creativity
in the space of a few words.
His architecture is a bold
and visionary critique of the
soulless shelters and buildings
being done all over the
world for impoverished
population and for refugees.
And part of his success comes
from his profound engagement
with the refugees themselves.
Before embarking on any project,
Rizvi Hassan holds workshops
with the Rohingya refugees,
including the children,
trying to find out their
ideas and their suggestions.
This of course takes time, because
it requires earning
their trust beforehand.
But as a result of these workshops,
he identifies craftsmen, craftswomen,
artists, carpenters, weavers, teachers,
and is eager to hear their
ideas, and then they collaborate
with him so that the
final project reflects
what they have suggested to him.
The Rohingyas who fled genocide in Myanmar
are a stateless minority.
They have absolutely nothing.
They possess nothing
but intangible heritage.
And these projects,
Rizvi's projects with them,
reflect and give body, shape,
and form to this heritage.
Rizvi Hassan has designed a
series of centers in different
Rohingya camps, all
with different projects,
a cultural memory center that
addresses issues of memory and identity,
A safe space for Rohingya women and girls,
and a Hindu-Para Center
for a small Hindu minority.
The Rohingyas are mainly Muslim,
but there is a tiny minority,
and the Hindu-Para Center is
extremely important, because it
is shared with the Bangladeshi community,
so with the host community.
What stands out of this
collaboration with the refugees,
is a work that is utterly
sophisticated and known
for the beauty, the exquisite beauty
of the detailing and the sense of color
and joy that emerges from these projects.
But you have to see them for
yourself, and no one is more
knowledgeable and more eloquent
in explicating his own work
than Rizvi Hassan himself.
So in the name of everybody
who's attending this lecture,
I wish to welcome Rizvi Hassan to Yale.
It is a real honor to have
you speak to us today.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Esther,
for introducing me with such kind words,
I'm flattered to be here.
And I'd like to thank the whole
platform who organized this
and arranged this scope of discussion
between a larger community and this one.
So basically what I'm gonna try
to do here today is share my
experience with the Rohingya refugees
in the past five years.
So what we have done,
how we get to know them,
and what were our
observations and learning.
I mean, working with them has been
a massive change of our own
philosophy, ambition of life as well.
And I'll just try to share this with you,
and I'd very much like to welcome
if anyone has any
questions or observations,
any kind of understanding,
please do share and we
can have a discussion.
I'll just share the slides.
So you know, Bangladesh
is a delta landscape,
and this is one of the
largest delta in the world.
And many architects here has
been working on how really you
need to work on a changing landscape.
Our whole country is
literally created on silt,
a lot of rivers, a lot of streams,
and that makes the landscape changeable.
And we had the opportunity to
look up on many great architects
from Bangladesh who are
already practicing in the
field, and trying to figure out
this new method or new trend
or new technologies that can
really go with the lifestyle
of a changing landscape.
And part of that, as a part of that,
we have been working in
different cities like Dhaka,
Jhenaidah, Cox's Bazar,
Ukhia-Teknaf, or Sylhet,
and in different situations.
And the part of the journey
was to really determine who we
are in this landscape, and
what should be our role as
architects in this country,
or in this region even.
And that's how it started.
And we went to the camp in 2018.
I'll tell you a bit about the camp.
You know, the influx happened in 2017.
The big influx, around a million refugees,
Rohingya refugees, that fled from Myanmar
to Bangladesh overnight.
And it happened before 2017 as well.
But that was like in a very small scale,
like 20,000 people, 30,000 people.
They used to come from
1992 to this country,
often in a regular basis.
But this is the first time
such a big influx happened, in 2017.
And it was a genocide, to us,
what we could see, whether
it was official or not,
but it was a massive thing.
And later they started
building on the Teknaf Hills.
The massive camp was being
built like overnight.
You see, this was actually
reserved forest of Bangladesh,
what you see here.
And overnight, within weeks,
two weeks or three weeks,
these old trees were gone,
and they were just building
shelters, toilets, to support
this massive community.
And slowly it started growing like a city.
So what we observed is
that from 2017, to 2018,
it was kind of an emergency
phase, where everyone really
rushed and give their everything
to support with the basic facilities.
I mean, there was no roofs,
there was no wash facilities.
People couldn't understand if
they're walking on mud, or was
it human waste or...
it was fairly messy situation.
I mean, 1 million people was a big deal.
And from 2018 to 2019,
it was mostly like a
post-emergency phase, where
it was more about how we can
organize the whole camp now,
in terms of planning,
road networks, facilities,
all sort of thing.
And then the development phase,
I mean we observed a
lot of things going on,
like a service mentioning mental health,
health facility, and
your identity, culture.
It was all slowly being recognized
in this 2020, '21 and '22.
So this is a photo from Jhenaidah.
We worked before that camp here,
and we observed many
people working together.
Like, there is no architect in this photo,
but how they really plan the city together
with the help of one or two architects.
It was very fascinating to us,
and we learned it from
Khandaker Hassibul Kabir,
another architect who is
our mentor, and he does this
collaboration with general
people, or all sort of
community members and try to
build the environment together.
And we learned from that,
and we tried to do the same,
almost do the same in
the refugee camp context,
as we were very much fortunate to see
that process in front of our eye.
And later we were able to apply that
in the camp situation as well.
So the people you see here,
these are all our team
members in the last few years.
We found a lot of people
who were working there,
rushing to support the whole situation.
And they were very passionate
people who wanted to support
anyhow, with whatever they have in hand.
It didn't matter if you were
a doctor or an architect or
whichever professionally you were,
everyone was there to do
anything, just day and night.
And we became friends to them.
We designed a few facilities
for the situation,
and many things went wrong
and many things went right.
We started learning who
the refugee community is,
who the Rohingya people are.
It took us almost six months to
really understand the people there,
to really understand the
sociopolitical scenario
there and what's going on,
where it should go to
understand the government rules,
what should be done,
and what should be the ethical side
of doing what we are doing.
And slowly, we tried to
experiment with many projects,
that we did in a very softer approach.
Like we didn't want anything heavy
or anything big or massive
in the early phase because we could
do a lot of mistakes there.
So this is a project, this is
a project for Rohingya women.
It's in camp 25.
It's called Safe Space for
Rohingya Refugee Women and Girls.
This is the first project where
we could really collaborate
with the artisans, with the refugees.
And it was the first practice
to build some space together.
What you see here is a
mix, it's a camp, again,
it's a host community as well.
I mean you see a lot of shades,
the blue or the white shades,
these are mostly the
Bangladeshi community,
the hosting nationals.
And you will see a lot of
shelters within this context.
Like this is a camp where
there's a mixed of host community
and the refugee shelters,
like for example,
on the right top side, these
are the refugee shelters,
the dense ones are the refugee
shelters, that sort of thing.
And what happened was we got
to know from our friends from
the GBV team, Gender Based Violence who
deals with gender based violence that
a lot of problems are rising,
because of this mix of
these two communities.
A lot of violence, a lot of
threats, a lot of conflicts,
especially on women and girls,
that was coming to the scenario.
And we were working
with BRAC at that time,
and BRAC decided to deal
with the situation and they said, "Okay,
maybe we can sit with them and
try to consult what we can do
and maybe create a platform
where we can actually share
these thoughts and share this conflicts
and try to deal with in a
legal way or professional way.
And this was the space or structure
that we designed with them.
It was suggested, or the
communication was made with the
women that what they want to feel safe.
So they said, okay, the
camp is very brutal and
they don't feel safe or
relaxed in any room, any space.
You see all the boxy shapes there.
They don't feel safe there,
because people peek through,
and you can see everything,
what's going on,
they can hear you.
So what we suggested, okay,
maybe we can create an interior
court, open up to the inside
and which is very colorful and
vibrant, and there are a lot
of layers surrounding to it.
And that probably will offer
you a better sense of privacy.
And this was the space.
You cannot really see what's
going on inside from outside.
It's a very ragged thing,
but the inside is very,
you have the colors.
I mean, you feel open up when
you were in the courtyard.
And it was a success for us
because a lot of users were coming.
Even, I want to share one story
that I liked most about this
structure, is that we were
observing many these sort of
facilities in other camps.
And what we observed mostly is that
the male members of the community,
they don't feel very secure
to let their female members go
to such a facility.
They think that it's a cultural threat,
it's a religious threat, and many issues.
So they always used to say
no to the female members,
"Don't go to a facility,
that is run by an NGO
without our permission,"
and that sort of thing.
But the fun thing is when
we started building this,
everyone started calling this a stadium.
The the male members especially,
they were crafting the
space and they said,
these were the craftsmen.
And they said,
"Please hire us in this facility."
And we said,
"This is a woman facility,
why do you want to be hired here?"
They thought for a while
and they said, "Okay,
then I'll send my mother
or my wife or my daughter
to attend in this facility regularly."
So this was the first
time we thought, "okay,
maybe the space is actually
making some change."
I mean, we didn't heard this from
the male members for a long time,
that they were trying
to send female members
in a positive manner.
But this story was a success
for me in this project.
And now the host community come
here, the refugee community
comes here, and they often
discuss about their problems.
I mean, it's a problem.
It's a lot of problem
in their regular life,
but they get to have a
sense of joy in a space,
in a very brutal context.
Sometimes this space
turns to a green space,
and they let it grow.
And it's fun to watch that way.
And later, this is another
project after that one,
this was another project in the
Hindu-Para Community Center.
So the Hindu-Para,
I'll talk a little bit about
the Hindu-Para refugee camp.
You see in the drawing on the right side,
it's a very dense settlement.
That is the small camp for the Hindu,
community people who
are Hindu by religion.
And in the left it's the host community,
that is Muslim.
So, you know, Rohingya
refugees are mostly Muslim,
90%, more than 90%, they're Muslim people.
But this small Hindu community happened to
fled with them during the influx,
and they were isolated from the main camp.
So there was a conflict
regarding religion.
So what we found out is
that they were more insecure
in terms of like being
friends with each other and
communication and everything.
When we went there,
they were very insecure,
that they thought we're gonna again,
do some harm to them,
or break their temple
or that sort of thing.
So we decided not to work in the camp,
but just add this into
the camp, so that it is a
softer approach, that we do not
directly go inside the camp,
but we build something
nice and invite them,
and try to build the trust
slowly in the process.
And then we thought,
okay, maybe this facility
can also be used by the host community
when the refugees are gone.
So this was a structure where
we did also a lot of technical
experiments, like all
the panels are modular.
You can really, dismantle
this one and shift it
to some other place, or it's
less wastage technology,
that very modular design.
Everything is cut within the
dimensions and easy to install.
So this was the before scenario.
We found a abandoned shed,
that was a chicken, poultry shed,
but it was abandoned, and we
rented it and we converted the
same exact idea to a new space.
I mean, we didn't even try to
plan it or extend the rooms,
whatever we had, whatever the room was,
we just converted it to
a new community center.
And you see the walls,
these are all modular
panels that are attached,
and just made, they're steel-framed.
These all can be
dismantled, because the camp
is a very unpredictable situation.
We saw a lot of structures
being demolished within a night.
The camp in charge, government official,
they would come and they would say, "Okay,
we have to move this from this side, and
we have to make space from something else
for something else."
So this happened a lot.
And we thought, why not experiment
with some technology or some technique
where we really can do
this modular solution.
And this was acceptable, and
everyone loved that solution,
even the donor, because the donor,
they spent a lot of budget,
a lot of money on these structures.
But within one year or two years,
these structures are like gone,
and you cannot salvage anything.
But in this solution,
you can almost salvage everything from it.
You can just use this any time you want.
And you see that color, the essence,
the texture was very important
for us, because we tried to
connect with who there, I mean
with with their skin color,
with their clothes,
what they can relate to.
And it was not very difficult because
we looked around for clues,
whatever was in the surrounding,
and we tried to bring the solutions,
and compose the solutions.
And later they had fun.
When it was inaugurating,
they were painting the space,
they were enjoying the
colors and everything.
And in a similar technique,
we built a lot of structures
for the hosting villages as
well, for the Bangladeshi
community, not just the refugees.
Because it was also about balancing,
balancing the conflict or peace
between these two communities.
Because the host community,
they were addressing
these issues that, okay,
the refugees are getting
a lot of facilities
because of their influx,
where the host communities are still poor
and they don't get anything.
And the government had
this rule that okay,
maybe 25% to 30% fund will be spent
for the hosting nationals.
And this was one project that
we did for them among several.
And in the meantime,
we also supported the
government with our solutions.
This was a government
building on the left that was
converted in a very short time.
Probably took three months
to design and construct.
Now all the meetings,
all the ideation or decisions
are made in this building.
This project helped us build
trust with the government.
I mean they started understanding, okay,
an architect can offer something in
a very short time period.
And they don't take
like two years to design
and construct for three years now.
But this is not very perfect,
but this helped us a lot.
And these are few projects we did
later in the same technique.
We also did some experiments
where we used to live,
this is the left home, you see,
we converted it to the
right one, the left home,
the owner, he drives the car.
He's from the community where we
used to live and we thought, okay,
maybe we do a little bit experiment
here in the host community.
And we did the space, and turned
it into a studio like this.
And he was very happy.
And he's a friend of ours now.
this is one project that we did almost
in the last phase of the camp development.
I mean, after working
in many other centers
or many other camps, UN IOM, UN migration,
they decided that they wanted
to deal with the identity and
cultural issue of the Rohingya community.
And this was a project
under the mental health and
psychosocial support unit of IOM.
It started, with few cultural activities
or creative activities,
and they tried to figure out who
the Rohingya communities
are with their products,
with their techniques,
bamboo weaving, basketry,
which are stories, oral stories,
and stories from children, the elderly.
And they discovered that
this is a huge thing.
I mean their stories, their culture,
their identity is something
that we are completely overlooking.
We are just building shelter, shelter,
shelter, shelter for them.
But we are actually not trying
to understand that they are
actually a community that
has their own unique identity
and a lot of stories,
lot of skills, that they
can share with the work.
And at that time, Manuel Marques Pereira,
who was the Chief of Mission from IOM,
he was a very efficient
person, and he and the team,
they formulated this project, said, "Okay,
maybe we do a project that
really changed the idea of
Rohingya community
completely to the world,
how we can do that?"
So we were involved at that time,
and we were called and we
started the ideation, okay,
how we really can involve
and really can understand.
And so what we did was we
did a lot of workshops and
one-to-one interactions and
person-to-person interactions
and with elderly, with the children,
with the female group, community
leaders, and really try to
understand their stories,
as simple as that.
And we entered some design workshops.
It's in the camp, you see the back
wall is almost like turning down.
That is almost breaking apart.
But this was our shape.
This was our office space in the camp.
And these were all the
refugee volunteers there.
And many were carpenter,
many were school teachers
and university teacher from the Myanmar.
And they started gathering through
this team, and they shared
all sort of idea, history,
all sort of information.
And you see the boat
there, they made it here.
And this was made by (indistinct)
you see the old guy here, (chuckles)
he's a very tough type of person,
a very hotheaded person,
and he makes the most beautiful boats
you can imagine in the community.
So we started having fun with these guys,
having design session with these guys.
I always remember that how we had
classes in the universities.
Like I'm from the University
of Engineering and Technology.
I mean, I always tried to
replicate that in the camp.
I mean they don't have to
be the university students,
but we can have the same sort
of knowledge, sharing things.
We can have classes, we
can have studio, tools,
we can do things together.
And it was not very expensive because
they are carpenters,
they have the tools and
they have wastage materials,
and they used to make this out of quite...
it didn't need much budget for that.
And we found out a lot what they can make
and what they can draw.
What were their imagination like.
In one studio day we asked
them to design a panel,
a wall that no one has ever seen.
I mean we didn't say anything but just,
we said "Design a weird wall."
And this is a drawing
by Zaber (indistinct)
He's an artisan.
So he made his panels from the,
that is a window panel, but
that can be converted to a
table and a chair, you know?
So the wall is not just a
wall, it's also functional.
And we didn't ask for this model from him,
but he made it either way.
I don't know why.
But that excited
everyone, that said, okay,
we are dealing with something
very exclusive here,
and passionate people here.
This was his portfolio.
You can see his name is
written in the journal.
So we try to find out stories,
things, even within the
group of IOM in our office,
we try to gather as much
information as we could,
because when we are dealing
with the community and
we're saying, okay, it's a
Rohingya cultural memory center,
I'm not the person to
decide who is Rohingya.
The information that I'll get,
if I can compose that or assemble that,
or we can make use of that for betterment,
probably that will give some
sense of their identity.
Not all, but maybe some sense.
So we try to gather a lot of information,
and anyone's idea, anyone's thought,
anyone's comment, and we found out
many techniques that they use.
Again, workshops, you
see that on the right,
these are our master artisans teaching
to their students the nipa
palm technique for the roofing.
This technique is almost lost.
I mean, in Bangladesh you
cannot find it anymore,
but we try to revive this through them.
And this is very effective.
This technique is actually very effective.
I mean, we use thatch in
many roofs, but the thatch,
the problem is that has
to be replaced every year.
I mean every year you have to
do this investment to replace
the whole roofing system.
But this technique, the nipa, it lasts.
It can last for 10 years.
I mean if you can tie it up properly,
it can last for 10 years.
So we said okay, it's a big facility.
We cannot just change
the material every year.
We have to use this.
And it also goes in that culture.
And lot of simulations happen.
You see on the left side,
this is a drawing by an
artisan, we asked him to
think of a meditative
space or a peaceful space.
While he will find peace in the camp,
he has drawn this plan, you know,
it has a lot of layer like the veranda,
the semi-outer space.
And there are rooms,
there is another space.
And in the middle there is a courtyard
where you can see the light.
So subconsciously in our original design,
it translated somehow.
And you see the space now like this.
So the idea of this space is
it's kind of a living museum.
People come here, they have trainings,
they talk to each other, they
see the cultural objects.
There is a display, changeable
display all the time.
And it changes time to time
and there are some permanent
exhibit, you know, so it's sort of
a breathable space for us within the camp.
I don't know if it really
fits the definition of museum,
but it's a breathable space for us.
And the process, it was class every day,
every day it was a fun class to attend.
And we also had concerts. (laughs)
So some Rohingya singers,
they're singing to
entertain the craftsmen,
the construction workers.
And that lifted everyone's
spirit when we said, "Look,
this is a Rohingya cultural memory center,
and you need to come
up with all the ideas.
I am not the one who is
gonna tell you what to do.
I can compose with you, I can help,
but you need to come up with ideas."
And they came up with the
most absurd ideas you can see,
and most beautiful ideas,
most with their technique,
what they can do
precisely with the bamboo,
with the cane, with the
wood, with the mud, with art.
And they just drafted the whole thing.
This is the small wall of
memories, or wall of windows.
Every window is made by
an individual artisan.
And that window says about
their story or memory.
You can open a lot of
panel and you will see
a small flower, cow, the rice field.
And that says a lot of
stories in one world,
to be shared with a young generation
who is being born in the camp,
never seen their past life in Myanmar.
And they can just somehow relate to
the oral stories that the elderly shares.
This is Idris Bai.
That is Hassan Bai.
Hassan Bai made me a table.
This is a very portable table.
You can fold this one,
you can carry this on your shoulder,
take to construction sites,
put your laptop and work there.
Like he was observing
that I work on floors
or on on a wooden panel, whatever I get.
And come bring my laptop there.
And he said, "okay,
I'll make you a table."
And this was such a beautiful table.
I have never seen something like this.
And I now carry it everywhere, almost.
Is at the final drafted spaces.
That is Imam (indistinct)
And the beautiful thing is whenever
we go to these spaces now,
I mean, they sometimes say they just
come to this space for no reason.
And they come here, they sit,
they talk to each other
because one shelter is very...
it's so competitive for
like 20 family members
or 15 family members.
It's not very, I mean,
it doesn't bring you much joy in a complex
space often, or sometimes
it may stress you out.
So they come with their family
members or alone to the space
to have a sense of clean
and sense of light.
And in the middle that was Dimitrov,
He is a psychologist, he's an Ukrainian.
And we had a lot of conversations as well,
how we can really connect
with mental health,
this creative process.
And now he's in Ukraine.
He had to leave the scenario
before the construction was
over, but he was observing
the whole process.
And he said that this is the
first time he saw a creative
process or architecture really
has to do something with mental health,
and it really connects.
I mean, when everyone was
enjoying singing, he said, "Okay,
this is something you can really measure,
there is no doubt."
And we send him photos
(chuckles) in WhatsApp.
I hope he's well, his family as well.
But remotely, the photos make him smile.
And yeah, this space now is actually
a very important one because
almost all the officials, all
the most important officials,
the government officials,
they come here whenever to visit the camp.
They definitely come to the
Rohingya culture memory center,
to daily understand who are Rohingya.
And now they have a complete
different sense about this
whole community that okay,
this whole community is not
just a wild community or
someone who cannot do anything.
No, they can do a lot of thing
and they cannot be neglected.
The world has to take this community
seriously, no matter what.
And later we managed,
we worked with many other organizations
like some NG forum here.
And this was in our villages,
in Bangladeshi communities.
And we really, what we
really observed or understood
is that migration,
maybe that was an international migration,
or what we were dealing
about what the refugees.
But internal migration is
a big issue in Bangladesh.
People are leaving their
homes and villages.
They don't have much clue what
to do in villages anymore.
And they try to get to the city.
The city is a mess, messy situation.
There are slums.
I mean in a lot of case this
is worse than refugee context.
There's no competition, definitely.
But in a lot of case, people don't care
about the villagers who go to the slums,
stay unhealthy, no life.
I mean, so now what we are trying to do
is we are trying to
enter into this villages,
and trying to create
some sort of example that
will tie the people with where they are.
That will create good examples
in the community and build on the place.
You don't need to really
shift for life to the city.
Yes, you can go to the
city, you can go visit,
you can go for different facilities,
but you don't need to leave
what you have for such a
beautiful landscape you have.
And how we can really create
good examples in the villages.
That is our prime goal now.
And we are working on that.
We're trying to plan with
them, share with people.
This is a corner from one same workshop,
like in the morning the kid
was doing this, and in the hall
this guy was like, they
were doing the same thing.
And we were surprised
to see the similarities
of these people, the kids and the people.
So I thought, yes, everyone enjoys this,
the drawing, the building together.
And, in last year there
was a flood in Sylhet area.
We went there for a very short time,
tried to understand what is
happening, what can be done,
and tried to learn a
lot from them as well.
And we made a small raft
for them that can be for the
mothers of children
because during the flood
the lands get very isolated.
People often cannot get connected,
or they cannot carry their furniture,
their household items to a safe place.
So we thought, okay,
we went there for a week and
we experimented on a raft,
how this can be maybe a tiny classroom,
and it can be used as a
transport during an emergency.
It was not really a project,
but it was a project where
we can really get into the
context, get to know with the people.
And we made some friends there.
We found some artisans,
some female artisans.
They make beautiful weaving mats.
I have never seen this in
Bangladesh, in anywhere.
We found those beautiful pieces.
And this last week maybe,
we brought those mats to Qatar Summit,
there is an exhibition and,
they were sold to people,
and this fund went to the artisans,
the female artisans
from these rural areas.
And that's how we're trying
to connect like from different
rural spaces where they probably
have not seen city much,
but they are now being connected.
They're exhibiting their product
to a exhibition in Dhaka through us.
We're just trying to be helpful anyhow,
even through a toilet.
Like we wanted to design a toilet
because that was their primary
need, one of the primary
needs, a nice healthy toilet.
And we offered them that, we
had some fun and we said, okay,
don't just waste this on rice or, I mean,
because they had the food,
many people were coming with food,
rice, lentils and everything,
but they didn't want it.
They didn't ask for it.
So we thought, okay,
maybe on an emergency
we can do many things.
To some families we provided
them with materials,
what they can repair things with,
with this sort of toilet where
they can later extend and
make it a washroom as well.
So it was always organic.
It was never one decision
that we are going
for this and do this, no,
we always try to go to the context,
and try to understand, okay,
this should be the appropriate thing,
and we try to do that,
maybe next time we don't build a toilet.
So yeah, that's for impermanent life.
I think presence is very
important, because it's always
changing, it's always new decisions,
it's always new understanding and
your presence can make a lot of change.
That's our observation.
Whenever you were present there,
you were still there, and you
try to understand who you were
working with and what is the purpose.
If the budget, if the charity,
if whatever resource we have in hand,
if we try to figure out that,
we don't need to do everything,
we just need to do the
appropriate things sometimes.
Try to figure out what are
the appropriate things,
and that's when magic happens,
and that's how we are calling
it a presence for a wider spectrum.
Thank you.
That's all from me.
I'll stop that slide.
- I just have a couple
of questions, which are,
like, in the pictures that you shown,
there are lots of greenery
and trees around, and in some
other pictures that I have
seen from the refugee camps,
Rohingya refugee camps in
Bangladesh, they are very dry.
Is that the misconception,
that of the picture that I have
seen before, or did just happened to be
that where you built this center,
there were all these
trees that have been there
for a while because I think
that gives a lot of...
I mean it's like a transition in between
the place, it gives a sense
of peace and tranquility
rather than seeing
all these dry space around.
- The Ukhiya-Teknaf area, we
have total internal 32 camps.
The most photos you see that is in Ukhiya,
that is the most concentrated zone.
But we also have a lot of
scattered zone in the periphery,
which really matches with
the hosting villages.
And the projects we have,
I have shown you in first two projects,
those were in those areas
where the refugee community is
matching with the host
communities, and those actually
support both the refugees
and the host nationals.
So those are very, those are still green.
But for example, the Rohingya
culture memory center,
that is exactly in the
middle of the whole camp.
And you see all the shelters surrounding,
but the good thing is, when you go now,
you will see a lot of green,
people have worked on that,
on projects how to make a greener, cooler,
and how to revive whatever we had.
But the first two or three years
it was very barren, very barren.
It felt like a desert.
But now the scenario is a lot better.
The green is there, it's cool,
the camp is way more livable.
- Rizvi?
- [Rizvi] Yes.
- Thank you so much for that very moving
and very beautiful talk.
I mean, the work is so creative,
and I was struck again how you have
offered the Rohingya with
whom you have worked,
a support for heritage and so,
both heritage and memory.
And so the architecture
becomes a conduit for this,
but I realize also it becomes therapeutic.
So you do address mental health,
that is one of one of the
very strong things that,
it comes across that
it becomes therapeutic,
as I wish you would talk
a little bit more about
these and the stories that you shared,
which are so powerful and they are unique.
You're one of the few architects
who've worked with genocide.
So that already puts you
in a unique position.
- Yes, I mean from our
perspective, what we try to do is,
at the beginning we thought,
maybe it's just trauma
that we are dealing with.
It's just a bad memories.
And the genocide,
the genocide was such a
difficult time for them, that we
overlooked what they had
in past, the good memories.
And we were, people were lot focusing
on how you get rid of
that trauma that you had,
but they were not talking about
what good memories you had,
what songs you used to sing,
what poetry you used to have.
So sometimes, I don't know,
probably memory and
understanding, probably
we underestimate them
sometimes, that probably it's a
compartmentalized thing, that
we think they're refugees,
that's how they need
to be treated in a way.
But they're also regular
human being as well, right?
So what they have, they like to have joy,
they like to dance, they
like to be motivated.
They don't always like to talk about
what they're going through.
No, they don't.
They often get very distressed.
I mean whenever a journalist
is coming and asking all these
difficult questions that stress them out.
But when you are going,
sitting with them in a tea stall
and talking about, you know,
who is your girlfriend?
Who is your boyfriend?
That's when they start enjoying, okay,
we have a life in camp.
We have not lost everything.
We have the hope to grow from here.
So that was our technique.
We always try to avoid from
our side to talk about the
genocide or the tough situation,
try to make the event joyful.
But there has been a lot of
time where people used to come
to us and seek for help like
little girls, and guys who were
in trouble, and in many issues.
And we used to say, "Okay,
go to this person, he can help you,
the government can help you.
We used to refer them.
So we were very aware that okay,
they might come to us with
these problems, that is okay,
but we don't have to
talk about that always.
So that's how, we try to enjoy, that's it.
- So we have a question from Anisha Saha,
she's from the Department of
Southern Southeast Asia Studies
at the University of Calcutta.
And she says that the work
that you, Rizvi are doing is
absolutely something the
world needs to admire
and take inspiration from.
And her question is regarding
the data in relation to
gender-based violence in the camp,
that often led to early
pregnancy among teenage girls.
Is there such a case in Bangladesh?
And if yes, how is the
organizations you work with
are thinking with that?
And the second question
that she has is that,
when you are in the process of
building this lovely shelter,
was there any encroachment
issue raised upon the
organization by the government
or any other Bangladeshi
regional national?
- So the first question
is, yes, definitely.
I mean it happens a lot.
And in our team we always
try to have energetic female
members like Kaja Fatme,
who is also an architect.
She used to work with us in
many projects, and volunteers,
like female volunteers.
So these were, because a lot of these
issues used to arise and they used to
come with these problems, little
children, adolescent girls.
And they never used to share this with us.
Definitely, especially not the guys,
but they share it with
another female person.
And that happened a lot of time.
And there are special teams,
gender bill fellow team,
who has the counseling service,
who has the case management services
and they deal with these issues.
Any complex issues that arise,
they try to offer any
health related service.
They try to offer any
legal related service.
So BRAC, ActionAid, and
many other organizations,
they have these services.
So the center you saw in the beginning
that that has a courtyard inside.
One of the room is a counseling room,
one of the room is a case management room.
So there is always someone there
who is there to support these females,
maybe because they often don't
share this in front of everyone.
So we had to make some private
spaces so that they can come
and feel safe and share
this in a private manner.
And another thing,
encroachment has not been
an issue because the
government in the beginning,
they set in the map in
the plan that this land
will be for the camp.
And when we used to build in
the host community or in a village,
we used to have this dealing
with the landowner that, okay,
we are renting this for five
years or six years and they
give us the land and we build a structure.
And we have this understanding, okay,
when we leave, you can use the structure
or the community can use
the structure, that thing.
So encroachment was not an issue.
- You mentioned that the roofing,
the thatching technique that
is used, goes with the culture
and I was just wondering
if that is something
that has been in place, you know,
forever or is there more of a
story that you could tell us
about how that technique relates
or is integrated with the culture?
- The roofing technique?
Yes, so the nipa technique,
what we found out is that we
talked to this craftsman and
they said almost 90% houses
back in Myanmar, they used to build this
with this material.
So about nipa leaf is that
this grows on the salty canals
only in the salt water
sites in the canals.
And you cannot find it in
regular water area or something.
So in Myanmar they grow a lot
of these leaves, and they used
to have built with this leaf
a lot, and specifically the
technique that you have seen in the photo.
They seal the leaves with
the stick of bamboo and
use it like a tile, you
know, one on another.
And one day, what happened is that
we made a sample of this and we are
taking this by hand with us in the camp.
And many people started
gathering and they said,
"Where did you get this?
This is from our home," and
random people from the camp.
So that's how it was connecting.
We're saying, okay,
this is really working.
And we thought, okay, why not?
Maybe add some workshops.
We add this workshop in another
camp in Teknaf to distribute
the knowledge from the
elderly craftsmen to the young
who doesn't have any
clue about the technique.
Even for our country,
this was used before,
but now they don't use it anymore.
So it was a learning for us as well.
We didn't really know about the technique
we learned from them.
Now in the Qatar summit,
we made a wall with nipa palm leaves
and many people started asking,
"Okay, is it a coconut leaf?"
I said, "No, this is a leaf that
you should know (laughs)
and you should use."
So that's how it's being connected.
- Hi, I have a question if that's okay.
First, thanks so much for
sharing your work with us.
It's really incredible.
And I wanted to ask if you
have any advice for students,
like architecture students
who are interested in working
with refugees in a similar lens to you.
Since like I'm from, I'm
Esther's student at Yale,
and like resources online tend to
be either very limited
or just limited to formal
organizations like the UN,
and there's also this added
concern of it having a
sort of like neocolonialist
approach for students who are
not like local to the region.
- I mean, yes, if someone is not local,
or they don't have much difficulty
to have these connections,
build connections
and ability, it's okay.
I mean you can build a team
or you can get connected with
the team, with the
locals, with the refugees,
make friends with them, and
try to connect in a voluntary
manner or with an organization,
whatever the scope is.
But it is possible because many,
many artists or other
professionals from other countries,
they started working with us.
They're working here still.
And what they do is
they team up, they have
a local person, they have some
volunteers from the refugees.
So there is a system
where you can blend in.
When you come to the
context, you are not alone.
You are not really dealing things alone.
But the key is what is your intention?
If you have the intention to help,
if you really want to come
with everything you have
and try to be useful,
people will understand that you are useful
and they will take your help.
I see a question from David Palazon.
David Palazon was...
David Palazon, if you can come online,
I'd be very much happy.
He was the curator of the project.
He's an artist, he's a filmmaker.
He has been a huge thing
for this project as well.
You have seen one photo of
him like working on the,
you know, workshop, one of the workshops.
So a lot of ideations,
he has been our teammate,
our project manager for a long time,
and we did this together.
So what was that question, David,
if you can ask directly at me?
- Can you hear me, Rizvi?
- Yes, David, how are you?
- Long time I see you.
Congratulations on the
award, and all the award.
I'm really happy and glad
to see the final result.
- Thank you so much.
- And yeah, my question as you know,
it was quite a complicated
project at RCMC.
Before you arrive and
after I left. (laughs)
Let's put it that way.
There was actually a question
there from somebody who was
asking whether you had faced
adversity by the authorities
and camp managers and the government.
I think that was quite
common, as you could explain,
or you know, it's not
as a straightforward as building
anywhere else in the world
because it's quite a temporary space,
and we don't know for how
long they're gonna be there.
And also there's all the situation
and that has a lot of complexities.
But my question was more
about the collection.
So as you know, we sort of conducted
a massive cultural mapping
with the community,
which landed in a sort of
production of a lot of objects
over a thousand objects
and tapestries and so on.
And although we have different
ideas and there was much
consultation with the community,
these defined different areas
as you explain, pottery, and
architectural models, and
boat making and so on,
you know, tangible and intangible,
all the music that we recorded
in the YouTube channel and so on.
So all this was like the
material that was supposed to
influence the space and
the walkthrough experience
and in the best of the capacity that
we were able to put this together
and inform and validate by the community,
and inform your skills, you know,
and be glad I found you because
we had a previous architect
before, which wasn't a very good person.
So you did an amazing good job.
So, you know, your engagement
with the community is a
primer, I have to say.
So congratulations on that one.
But yes, you know, to me
it's like the physical,
you know, the shaping of the culture.
- I mean, yeah.
So about the cultural memory center,
I mean it already took place
with you guys, with you,
there's Manuel, there
was Dimitrov, there's
other teammates, Raju, and it was
already taking some
organic form before, and
then you guys had us in the team and then
it shifted to another paradigm.
So the process of this whole
project was fascinating to me
because we had to really act on
what was the demand of the time.
It was the complexity of the government,
from the government.
It was the complexity
within the organization,
what we can do, what we cannot do.
And especially from the government,
because this sort of project
is not easy to get the
permission from the government, no.
And we had to wait for the
permission for a long time,
and I had to change the
drawings, the design,
simplify it as much as possible,
for like five or six times
and present it to them.
So it was always,
the point we are saying is
presence for a wider spectrum.
If we had given up at that time, okay,
the government is not agreeing
with us the first two times
or three times, then this
project wouldn't happen, right?
So what we try to do
with whatever we have,
we have the opportunity
to do without breaking the harmony,
without breaking the
sociopolitical scenario,
without harming anyone
or attacking anyone.
What is the best possible thing we can do?
That's how we simplified a lot of things.
Of course, I remember you had the
major guidelines were built by you,
designed by you, that what
should be the inside things,
and what should the
curation, the narration.
But then we faced, when you left,
we faced these issues
from the government that,
"You cannot do this project in the camp,"
and campaign chair, he was not convinced,
"No, this is a cultural project that
is not applicable in the camp."
So what we try to do,
we try to shift it a
lot to learning things
like learning space, training space.
And we had to convince them that
this is a mental health facility.
This is something that is
related to mental health.
Their culture is there,
but it's not luxury thing,
or it's not something that you can
have in Dhaka or other
cities or other communities.
What can be the translated
version for the refugees?
What can be the simplified way,
to not really be a threat to
also the hosting nationals.
We had to take that in mind,
and we simplified a lot.
The facades were like organics.
I don't know if you remember,
there was a large board on
the outside of the, we had
to erase all of this, right?
And even during the
construction, it was really,
I'll tell you, during
the construction period,
we got the support from the artisans,
but the time was short.
We already lost a lot of time
for the Covid period. (laughs)
And during this time, I don't know,
this was the best thing
we could come up with.
And, and I said it's the memory
that we will carry,
during the making of the
tiles, the partitions,
and even the curators,
the present curators.
They're working on the new
products, the new things.
And I'm sure they are
just working on growing
the whole thing more and more.
I'm not in touch with
the IOM team anymore,
but I have the
communication with artisans,
and I often see photos what's going on,
and they're gradually growing.
They're making small villages
or whatever we had in in mind.
I think it'll not stop.
It's not a fixed thing
that we're looking at it,
like if they stay here in five years,
probably you'll see something
more crazy growing there.
- No, for sure.
I mean, you know,
the guidelines were set and the map
is there to be explore and expanded.
But to me the soul of the building
was all these objects, you know?
I remember before there
was a building, you know,
because to me it was, you know,
I was hire as a curator of
a center that didn't exist,
of a collection that didn't exist.
So I have to create, you know,
the team that will create
with the community,
a collection that will tell
a narrative and you know,
and you have to make a building
to shape that narrative, you know?
So it was quite an
impossible project. (laughs)
'Cause the UN don't do cultural centers.
- No, they don't. (laughs)
- Anywhere in the world.
The least in a refugee camp. (laughs)
So, you know, people have,
what we went through to make...
And Manuel, you know, Manuel is, you know,
also he have to deal with many things.
We all did.
But I'm glad, you know,
is finally there and
in some sort of shape,
and content is evolving
into something that
the community can hold on onto in,
in the adversity of what they're facing,
which is unclear how
long, (chuckles) you know,
they have to be there, you know?
For sure.
It is framing to the MHPSS
sort of framework, because
that's how it is justifying the UN system.
But, it is very cultural.
- Exactly, but what's the
most beautiful thing is,
what you shared with
artisans, the trainings,
the house model making.
I mean, even if these products are gone,
these people are the living
legions of the community now.
I mean, you cannot deny that
even if the whole facility is not there.
This team, this massive
team is there to share,
to do all the right
things for the community.
And that's a huge success of you,
of the team, of us together.
- Yeah, they're growing too,
they're curating their
own life and culture.
They didn't know, you
see, we are the catalyst
that provide them with the
opportunity to be their own
curators and to be the culture men,
and sort of lead that cultural revolution.
Anyway, I will not stop.
Maybe I should let you keep going.
Thank you very much.
- Yeah, talk to you later, David.
- Hi, I actually have a question as well.
I already dropped my question in chat,
but I thought it'd be nice to ask it here.
I'm just wondering if you can
speak a little bit more about
the role of peace-building
humanitarian organizations,
nonprofits, and international aid agencies
in making the project that you do happen.
Since you mentioned the IOM,
you mentioned BRAC and a
few other organizations
I'm just wondering whether
their role in making your
projects happen are mostly
on the, you know, funding,
the program design side in
terms of the overall community
development programs, or they're
also providing, you know,
access to communities, and
also helping you lead with the
government to make sure that,
to kind of meet their vision
and their requirements.
Yeah, just speak a little bit about that.
Thank you.
- Yeah, I mean had this confusion
that whether we can explore to the
strict systems of UN
or other organizations,
and do these unconventional things,
but we had to take the
coverage to do that.
I mean, the funding was there,
the projects and you know,
the project has some sort of guidelines,
but when you are there as a catalyst,
and you say this is
the right thing to do under this project,
there is always chance to improvise.
There is always chance to
shift it a bit in the right direction,
and come up with a nice,
I mean, very appropriate
thing I would say.
We often think, okay,
these are the projects
I have to just do this.
That is the biggest
criticism of NGOs probably,
that they always operate from outside.
They bring the funding, they
have to just do this, this,
this, fill up the checklist.
And sometimes it's a mess instead,
but in many cases it's not a mess.
It's actually very helpful
and very beautiful,
and that's all because of
the person who is there,
who is operating.
I mean, in the organizations,
I have met so many brave persons,
so many visionary person,
who actually could think in a
creative way, in a visionary way,
and they could improvise
whatever they need.
They could even come up with new projects
like the RCMC, the Rohingya
Culture Memory Center.
The team worked to build
this project, right?
They created this project
under mental health.
So there is always chance for
the people who are in charge
to really have this visionary decisions.
And if you can really encourage them,
come up with a nice idea, and slowly,
you don't have to always push them.
Just slowly have discussions.
And there are a lot of people,
a lot of positive people
to really make change.
There are a lot of people
who don't want to do much.
They want to just (chuckles)
do their desk job,
but a lot of people are actually
making change and they're
actually do this benefits to the people.
- So I was just asked to thank
you for this extraordinary,
really deeply moving presentation.
We were honored to hear you,
and we look forward to having
this posted on our website,
and look forward to continuing
to follow your career
and congratulate and
salute you for everything
you have done for the Rohingyas,
and the path you have
shown to the profession.
That is no mean feat.
It's an extraordinary achievement.
So thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you very, very much.
- [Rizvi] Thank you so much.
- And thanks to all of
you for being present
at this event.
We will certainly be
following Rizvi Hassan
as he goes along at his career, thank you.
- Thank you so much for having us,
and I really enjoyed the time.
Hope to see you again.